[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I call for the immediate
arrest of Jared Kushner if he should not
be suspected of money laundering
racketeering and influence peddling than
he should be suspected of obstruction of
justice and espionage and possibly worse
there is no other option that can be
reasonably entertained 18 us code 794
section a gathering or delivering
defense information to aid foreign
government quote whoever with intent or
reason to believe that it is to be used
to the injury of the United States or to
the advantage of a foreign nation
communicates deliveries or transmits or
attempts to communicate deliver or
transmit to any foreign government or to
any faction or party or military or
naval force within a foreign country
either directly or indirectly
information relating to the National
Defense shall be punished by death or by
imprisonment for any term of years or
for life this is from the Espionage Act
arrest Kushner now the rest of that
statute limits use of the death penalty
to the exposure of the identities of
American agents or defense plans or
communications intelligence the Russian
ambassador to the United States
reportedly told his superiors that on
December 1st or 2nd of last year in the
building on Fifth Avenue in New York
City called Trump Tower that Jared
Kushner proposed using Russian
communication facilities in a Russian
embassy or a Russian consulate to
contact the Kremlin directly to make
certain the lawful government of the
United States could not prevent
interfere with or know of those
communications arrests Kushner now the
proposal was so startling so
unprecedented that even the Ambassador
Sergei kiswa a quote reportedly was
taken aback according to the Washington
Post The New York Times printed the
Kushner sides cover story this was a
means by which Kushner could get
information from the Russians about
Syria
the cover story given to the Associated
Press was that this was all for Michael
Flynn's opportunity to talk directly to
Russian military leaders
about Syria having already twice chosen
not to mention his meetings with
Russians on the sf-86 forms he swore
under oath in order to gain his security
clearance Kushner was reportedly himself
willing to enter or willing to have
other trump transition officials enter
diplomatic facilities which have
privileged legal status within the
United States and talk directly to
officials of the Russian government
even if this Syria excuses somehow true
Kushner was still intending to
communicate with a foreign nation a
foreign enemy nation about a second
foreign nation a second foreign enemy
nation and he would not have been asking
about the Russians assessment of the
weather in Syria this would have
pertained to Russian military
involvement there and could likely have
delivered quote either directly or
indirectly information relating to the
National Defense the Syria excuse could
still be espionage arrest Kushner now if
the Syria excuse is not true the banking
story may be true the Reuters news
agency quoting seven current and former
US officials reported Kushner had a
minimum of three previously undisclosed
contacts with ambassador kiss we act
during and after the presidential
campaign it cited one current US law
enforcement official in reporting quote
FBI investigators are examining whether
Russians suggested to Kushner or other
Trump aids that relaxing economic
sanctions would allow Russian banks to
offer financing to people with ties to
trump NBC in The New York Times are
reporting Kushner met last December with
a Russian banker named gore cough and
gore coughs Bank is the Russian
government's National Development Bank
and Gourcuff graduated from the Academy
that trains the Russian intelligence
personnel and that our intelligence
personnel consider Gourcuff a quote
Putin crony CNN is reporting the Russian
government officials even claimed to
have quote derogatory financial
information to use against Trump and his
staff during the election campaign the
banking story could be money laundering
or racketeering and/or in
fluence pedaling and it ties together
all too cynically with the renewal of
eb-5 visas in this country a renewal
stuffed into page 734 of House bill 244
signed by Trump on the 5th of May which
offers permanent residence in this
country to rich foreign investors who
put money into things like American real
estate projects it ties together all too
cynically with the impression Kushner's
family company left with Chinese
investors just two weeks before that if
they bought into Kushner real-estate
deals in New Jersey their immigration
process could be expedited and it
further ties together all too cynically
with the CBS news report that when word
spread that the FBI investigation of
Trump had expanded from potential
electoral collusion to finances and
investments Kushner became a quote
prominent voice advocating the firing of
James Comey and when it is all tied
together what that prominent voice was
advocating might reasonably be
considered obstruction of justice arrest
Kushner now and at the Syria excuse
which could still be espionage is not
true and if the banking story which
could be money laundering or
racketeering or influence peddling and
obstruction of justice is not true what
is left for what other evil purpose did
Jared Kushner want a covert secure means
of direct spy tested communication to
the Kremlin after a presidential
campaign in which his father-in-law
encouraged Russians to hack into the
computers of his electoral opponent why
would Jared Kushner want to go inside
the Russian embassy or the Russian
consulate the centers of Russian
espionage in this country after an
election about which the Russians would
boast of their influence why would Jared
Kushner need means to avoid the
detection of the government of the
United States after the direct evidence
of contact between his father-in-law's
campaign and ambassador kis lyac
throughout 2016
why would Jared Kushner want to keep his
contact with the Kremlin secret from the
intelligence services of the United
States after the mounting circumstantial
evidence of collusion between his
father-in-law's campaign and the
government of Russia
what would make Jared Kushner be willing
to tempt prosecution under the Espionage
Act to avoid his contact with Russia
becoming known to the President of the
United States arrest Kushner now Jared
Kushner brings us not just into the
White House he brings us both
figuratively and literally to the door
of the Oval Office inside that door
there are people who appear not to
understand why they are not permitted to
break the law when they think it's a
good idea to do so inside that door
there are people for whom running this
nation is not a solemn and nearly
religious responsibility but an
opportunity for wins and power and
financial corruption inside that door
there is a man in charge who has never
been stopped by rules and has never been
held accountable when he breaks those
rules these people do not believe in the
law these people do not believe in
patriotism these people do not believe
in the United States of America these
people Kushner his wife Trump general
Allen general McMaster general Flynn the
others are in their souls if not under
the law traitors to this country and no
matter which excuse Jared Kushner has
for proposing to talk to Russia using
secret Russian communications while
surrounded by Russian spies inside
Russian territory there is but one
answer arrest Kushner now resist peace